Question it. I have a lump on my lower leg doctor said he didn't think it was anything
Had two ultrasounds have a CT scan tomorrow doctor said he may have it removed
Worried about that iodide dye is that dangerous?
Okay, so
A lot of lumps, you know, it's really hard to answer this without actually see it and
looking at that
But a lot of lumps are
Superficial lumps on your surface on your skin, you know, most common thing would be a lipoma
But almost any doctor that has any experience can basically palpate that lump and tell
With with a fair degree of certainty whether it's a lipomo or not because it'll typically be movable, you know, feel like it's encapsulated and
And
But there's nothing wrong with getting some imaging done. So I think that's the right thing to do is to get some imaging done
I'm not sure what you're talking about with the iodide dye
A CT scan is going to have radiation in a CT scan with contrast
Is you know, you know, you're getting semi invasive there, but still you want to rule that out. You want to make sure
There isn't anything anything more serious
Most surface lumps on adults are going to be bedoied
If it's a child in a lump on their leg, that's very scary. You got different sarcomas. You have different
cancers that can be very serious as a younger person
But typically on an older person is it's in your thigh or something and you get a lump. It's
most commonly a podine
tumor
lipoma is one of the more common ones
And lipomas can be surgically excised very easily
If you don't have multiple lipomas
Typically they don't come back. I mean
People people can get people can have you know different lipomas come back
But it's not that that lipoba is spreadied or anything like a metastatic tumor or anything like that
so
It's good that you're getting it checked out. I wouldn't be overly nervous about it. It's but
It's definitely good to get checked out and getting lipoba removed typically
involves no danger whatsoever
It's very common occurrence